joining me today is comedian actress and
aunt to my daughters jill kargman
[Applause]
i dressed extra witchy for you for
halloweek
scary more week well you know you always
dress in black so
yeah no i'm always a witch but i
normally don't carry around this lovely
spider headpiece
by the way it reminds me of coco your
mom grammy
great she always wears that little
spider headband every halloween yeah
it's very philip tracy as lee said
yes it is okay well what is better than
halloween tick tocks
halloween tick tock's gone horribly
wrong
it's uh tick-tock costume fails first up
let's do this
some people are sharing their
unfortunate costumes from halloween's
past
on tick-tock we have a minion costume
let's see this one i can't see it it's
somewhere
oh no that oh wait oh yes there it is
or this one for a powerpuff girls
costume
um
yeah yeah it's like lee bowery i mean
it's like
kind of cool like i could see that oh
yeah
like at the clubs yeah yeah well we're
gonna
we're gonna be showing like tick-tock
fails all week long
um but i have to show a picture of a
costume that you wore that i
absolutely love yeah it's a little
bit of a far cry from your sexy cat it's
a
priceless right wheel some women try to
show their curves i just have
a giant curve i like
the showcase showdown i love bob barker
spay and new your pets barker's beauties
like that show was filmed right down the
street from my house
i was obsessed with it when i was a kid
and it's still kicking and rocking
with a drew i drew carrie yeah it's oh
yeah
i love that show too it was my my
favorite game show and i loved
by the way your halloween costume when
you were a kid
oh yeah which one oh yeah
by the way i was literally going into
like a major nightclub in that outfit
too
that makes sense yeah that's how my mom
and i kicked it we went to nightclubs
she was a blast
listen in other news i don't know if
you've heard but america's dentists are
losing it over
another hot tick-tock trend abc news
reports that young people
using are using nail glue to affix
dracula fangs onto their teeth
and then they can't get them off okay
and dentists are pleading
with people do not glue fangs
to your teeth nail glue is toxic and
you'll need help from a professional
dentist
to remove them yeah i think i mean i
know i look like a vampire but i'm not
one for fangs and i can't believe people
are that dumb but dentists are having a
really
rough fall last month they had to tell
america
not to file their teeth down at home
with a nail file
part of tick tock's molar makeover
challenge
i mean i just know that olive will walk
in the room
and everything now is a tick-tock
challenge like
if there's a buzz cut happening on
tick-tock she's gonna walk in with the
shade
totally like all the kids are really
like and it's not just kids it's like
adults
everyone's following the tick tock
challenge
yeah i'm not i like tick tock but it's
hilarious what's happening all right
moving on joel what's the scariest movie
of all time for you
um fatal attraction love it by the way
that's the best
just the jumping out of the bathtub i
screamed so loud
in the theater that i think i gave
people coronaries like i it's a lot the
only time i remember
actively shrieking i love that movie
so much but guess what according to
science
forbes magazine is reporting that the
science of scarce study
they measured viewers heart rates while
they watched
50 of the top rated scary movies of all
time
and they found out the scariest
according to scientific heart rates i
love stuff like that
is sinister starring ethan hawk about a
series of grisly family murders
and the biggest jump scare
belongs to insidious which came in
second
now everyone says these these movies are
just terrifying i
funny enough contrary to probably
popular belief
i am terrified of scary movies and do
not watch them
yeah but you're the scream queen i know
but like that's what makes it so i don't
watch them either i like a like a
psychological thriller
and stuff but any pop outs or just super
grizzly things i can't take
i am just like i used to watch a lot of
movies does anyone remember like the
changeling
or audrey rose um the exorcist
like yes when we were growing up scary
movies were like
they were a mental mind you know what
and now
it's just like everyone's worth worst
nightmare come true yeah but some people
i think
get like they enjoy the fear they they
like that
screaming well also what is better for
date night than the girl like
yes i think like you don't have to do
that yawn
and arm around boob grab because it's
just like
yeah you're just like i think scary
movies were designed to get like the
girl
excuse me yeah it's an icebreaker
because you're in it together it's like
us versus all the monsters well see
look we made scary movies a heart rate
in another
different way romance
[Music]